la storica vi racconterò che la un buon
funzionamento dello stato e della
pubblica amministrazione italiana è
stato la regola per molti anni nella
storia della nostra italia e che anche
oggi possiamo trovare nicchie di buon
funzionamento della pubblica
amministrazione che tuttavia
costituiscono un'eccezione dalle enormi
potenzialità andiamo al passato quando
nacque l'italia come voi tutti sapete
era un paese agricolo di semi analfabeti
che aveva pochissimi capitali e materie
prime a disposizione per uno sviluppo
industriale che era doveroso nel
nell'europa del tempo nel mondo del
tempo e aveva tante braccia lavorative
in più a distanza di 50 anni questo
paese era profondamente cambiato
era diventato un paese industriale
seppure con un'industrializzazione
concentrata nel triangolo e aveva
realizzato grandissimi progressi in
tutti i settori anche nel campo
dell'istruzione della mobilità delle
lotte a delle malattie endemiche come la
malaria
come sarebbe mai potuto accadere tutto
questo se non ci fosse stato uno stato
una pubblica amministrazione competente
ed efficiente ovvero una intelligente
regia pubblica dello sviluppo capace di
intercettare attraverso uomini di
qualità che se ne intendevano delle cose
che dovevano fare tutte le risorse
disponibili nell'intero territorio
nazionale
e infatti questo avvenne l'italia si
industrializza e riuscì con una sinergia
straordinaria fra governo e pubblica
amministrazione e parlamento e con una
sinergia straordinaria fra il nord e il
sud nella valorizzazione delle risorse a
trasformarsi in un paese industriale
così vago e le materie prime con le
esportazioni agroindustriali e minerarie
provenienti moltissimo dalle regioni
meridionali
pagò con le rimesse degli emigrati il
debito con l'estero
e riuscì a realizzare con il concorso
del risparmio degli italiani e il
risparmio da lavoro in patria e
all'estero a dare allo stato le risorse
per potere fare gli investimenti infatti
lo stato aiutò moltissimo allora
l'industrializzazione che fu concentrata
nel famoso triangolo tutto questo fu il
frutto di una scelta e per fortuna
abbiamo fatto condivisa e che ne dicano
molti storici in tutte le parti del
territorio nazionale
uno dei grandi processi di
trasformazione che dietro veramente un
grandissimo contributo allo sviluppo
economico italiano
la grande migrazione questa fase di
grandissima trasformazione lo stato e la
pubblica amministrazione italiana sono
furono capaci di realizzare un
monitoraggio di ciò che si stava
svolgendo di grande qualità innovativa e
mi riferisco all'inchiesta parlamentare
sulle condizioni dei contadini nelle
province meridionali e nelle isole che
possiamo considerare per diversi motivi
una specie di prima manifestazione di
open government naturalmente nelle forme
consentite dal tempo che erano quelle di
un enorme limitatezza delle possibilità
di muoversi delle possibilità di
realizzare informazioni rapide e di
comunicare queste informazioni
eppure questa inchiesta realizzata tra
il 1906 1910 fece ricorso alle opinioni
dei destinatari delle stesse politiche
ebbe questa caratteristica chi apertura
ai suggerimenti dei destinatari delle
politiche i tecnici andarono a visitare
da tra i 70 ei 170 comuni ciascuno vite
ci misero del tempo però fecero un
grandissimo dal lavoro di indagine e lo
fecero con l'idea che i presupposti da
cui erano partiti potessero cambiare
cioè in sostanza avevamo uno stato una
pubblica amministrazione anche una
politica diciamo l'ha disposta a
cambiare rotta
cioè a realizzare a studiare la realtà
disposta a cambiare la rotta delle
politiche pubbliche in rapporto ai
risultati acquisiti e infatti tutti
partirono con l'idea che l'emigrazione
fosse un grande sacrificio non era
certamente un un fenomeno determinato
dalla miseria e invece dovettero
constatare proprio parlando con i
contadini manconi direttore di gara
ambulanti del luogo con i parroci con i
capi delle leghe contadina che questa
emigrazione era vissuta dai contadini
come un grandissimo atto di libertà e di
opportunità potete scorrere nelle slide
alcune considerazioni dei contadini che
rispondevano al alle domande dei tecnici
parecchie se parecchio significative il
mondo è libero dovrebbero portare al
posto del ritratto di gesù cristo quello
di cristoforo colombo e comunque la cosa
più interessante fu la conclusione che
se ne trasse proprio da parte di
francesco saverio nitti che fu peraltro
un grande riformatore della pubblica
amministrazione l'inchiesta fu
paragonata al viaggio di cristoforo
colombo che partì alla ricerca delle
indie invece scoprire l'america e allo
stesso modo i tecnici dell'inchiesta
andavano a cercare nei contratti agrari
hangar ici nelle condizioni di miseria
le ragioni dell'emigrazione che fra
l'altro stava parecchio preoccupanti
proprietari terrieri per che salivano i
salari e invece avevano trovato questa
grandissima esigenza di trovare grandi
opportunità di lavoro e di realizzazione
nel resto del mondo che glielo
consentiva questo significava che
bisognava assecondare la migrazione ma
anche trovare in italia delle risposte
adatte a questa aspirazione e non a
quella che si immaginava all'inizio
fosse per la guerra come sapete
interruppe tutto questo percorso e
comincia un'altra storia che io non vi
posso raccontare che se parliamo della
pubblica amministrazione di oggi ci
cascano le braccia cioè vediamo fenomeni
di corruzione di sprechi abbiamo uno
scenario decisamente demoralizzante però
non possiamo per questo scenario
demoralizzante non vedere
e ci sono dei fenomeni di eccellenza
nella nostra pubblica amministrazione
che sono una eccezione e proprio per
essere un'eccezione nella pubblica
amministrazione non sono manifestazioni
o strutture perfette ma esistono e hanno
delle potenzialità tali per il loro
operare da offrire grandissime
prospettive non soltanto alla qualità
della democrazia ma anche alle
possibilità della ricerca rispetto alle
frontiere che questo tipo di azione apre
mi riferisco in maniera particolare
all'azione del dipartimento per lo
sviluppo e la coesione che una struttura
tecnica insediata nel 98 nell'ambito del
ministero del tesoro proprio per
accompagnare la spesa la gestione dei
fondi europei
il primo dovere che questa struttura ha
avuto dall'unione europea è stata quella
di rendere la spesa trasparente e di
rendere conto al pubblico online quindi
gli scogli strumenti infinitamente
superiori a quelli che avevamo
chiaramente all'inizio del novecento
rendere disponibile al pubblico
l'informazione su tutto ciò che riguarda
la spesa a tutti i livelli che sono
interessati a questo tipo di azione
pubblica
questo è avvenuto ma non ha dato
risultati soddisfacenti come voi sapete
questo dipartimento il cui diciamo la
cui il cui nucleo centrale è stato fatto
con un brain trust di persone di alta
specializzazione formatesi nelle
strutture della banca centrale della
banca mondiale e del terzo settore
quindi con un'esperienza internazionale
ecco questi questi soggetti che avevano
a cuore i risultati hanno constatato una
sottoutilizzazione tanto più colpevole è
da mettere sotto osservazione quanto più
sotto la pressione di una gravissima
crisi e colpito in maniera tragica
le regioni meridionali e i giovani
meridionali
quindi hanno avuto l'idea di aprire un
sito in cui potete trovare
tutti i dati sui settori di intervento
la spesa lo stato della spesa ma
soprattutto tutti i progetti ed entrare
quindi voi per temi luoghi e soggetti
attuatori esattamente in questa in
questa enorme banca dati queste norme
banca dati non è una piccola realtà
italiana perché si è inserita
all'interno di un processo di
costruzione di una banca dati molto più
ampia inaugurata dagli stati uniti
d'america dall'amministrazione obama
nel 2009 poi sostenuta dall'onu e ha
proprio fatto un'azione di promozione
delle pratiche di open government verso
i cittadini e quindi si tratta di una
pratica di trasparenza che
responsabilizza tutti quelli che fanno
parte del processo e cioè le ha tutte le
amministrazioni a tutti i livelli
attraverso i progetti da cui si può
leggere non solo lo stato di
realizzazione ma anche si possono andare
a cercare gli impedimenti alla piena
realizzazione quindi smascherare anche
fenomeni di corruzione fenomeni di
inefficienza
ma questa rete è stata aperta al
monitoraggio dei cittadini e quindi
consente a cittadini che non sono più i
cittadini sprovveduti o non
sufficientemente informati di un tempo
di entrare nei progetti specifici con
rapporti di monitoraggio open government
in particolare ha realizzato un'azione
molto interessante con una rete di
monitoraggio civico che si chiama
monitor cioè una maratona di
monitoraggio civico e insieme hanno
rappresentato l'italia all'ultima
edizione di open government ship
al 4 assi ficcandosi per le pratiche di
buona amministrazione soprattutto sul
tema del city training ashman sono
arrivati al quarto posto nel mondo prima
degli stati uniti prima dell'olanda del
regno unito che hanno pratiche di buona
amministrazione
molto più consolidate e noi stiamo
parlando di un pezzo di una grande rete
che se consideriamo lo spazio che copre
attualmente coinvolge stati che coprono
circa un terzo della popolazione
mondiale è un'opportunità che va colta
se andiamo a guardare la cartina
italiana prevediamo che fortemente
ancora sotto utilizzata per esempio per
la sicilia per cui esistono un sacco di
progetti pubblicati in open coesione che
avrebbero molto bisogno di correzione ed
implementazione li vediamo che per
esempio c'è un solo rapporto di
monitoraggio sul palermo ancora mentre
su catania non ce ne sono
questo è un invito a vedere tutti i
progetti approvati in open coesione e
che sono in corso di realizzazione e
vedere se effettivamente un cittadino
che non si debba limitare a dire non mi
piace l'amministrazione non funziona non
si può fare niente sono tutti corrotti
non abbia invece oggi il dovere di
rendersi parte attiva di di questo
processo
grazie